[Musique]
[Rires]
où
peu
[Musique]
allez c'est parti pour le stream du
dimanche alors aujourd'hui c'est
dimanche à 10h30 parce que ce soir
j'avais des activités sinon on essaie de
faire ça à 21h et aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on fait on va lire un article de
sciences sociales alors aujourd'hui ce
sera pas non plus des sciences sociales
à proprement parler sera plutôt de la
psychologie avec cet article sur les
intelligences multiples alors il ya eu
un petit sondage qui a été réalisé sur
la page youtube de la société où je
proposais trois articles il y avait un
article qui traitait plutôt de l'école
de l'école en france et des inégalités
scolaires en gros il y avait un article
qui parlait de l'engagement dans le
front national par rapport à la
reconstruction peut être identitaire ces
deux ces deux articles là était beaucoup
plus sciences sociales et ce qui était
intéressant avec ses articles là c'est
que il y avait vraiment une partie dans
peary alors que ces textes si vous allez
voir c'est beaucoup plus théorique et
donc c'est plus de la psychologie mais
voilà le public à voter le public a
parlé nous sommes ici dans une chaîne
démocratique et donc voilà on a fait
l'article qui avait été choisi je
proposerai trois nouveaux articles la
semaine prochaine ce qui va être super
intéressant c'est que j'ai réussi à
avoir un accès à la plateforme kern en
illimité grâce à lui celle louvain en
fait quand t'es pas universitaire ben
voila tu dois payer quasi tous les
articles en tout cas les articles plus
récents et comme je suis lecteur d'une
bibliothèque universitaire j'ai un petit
peu demandé si je pouvais avoir accès
aussi en ligne à tous ces articles
scientifiques et ça a été positif donc
ça c'est vraiment très très chouette
parce que je vais avoir une base de
données une base d'articles une base de
publications dans laquelle on va pouvoir
puiser vraiment des trucs plus
intéressant que si je devais me
contenter que des articles comment dire
gratuit voilà ça c'est un petit peu pour
la popote je vous rappelle aussi que on
se retrouve ensemble
le mercredi soir et le jeudi soir leur
mercredi soir on joue un jeu vidéo qui
parle de politique et j'appliquerai le
programme de fabien roussel mercredi
prochain donc mercredi prochain à 20h on
se retrouve uniquement sur twitch cette
fois ci et le jeudi il ya une émission
politique qui parle un petit peu des
présidentielles françaises qui parle un
petit peu qu'ils parlent totalement des
présidentielles françaises et là on a
différentes rubriques et toutes les
questions que vous vous posez vous
pouvez les poser et on essaie d'y
répondre ensemble donc ça c'est le
mercredi et le jeudi voilà donc
aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour cet
article sur les intelligences multiples
on voit que ce sont deux chercheurs
serge larivée et carole sénéchal de
l'université de montréal et d'ottawa
donc ce sont des canadiens faut savoir
qu'en pédagogie a quand même beaucoup de
publications au canada c'est vraiment
très très fécond à ce niveau là est donc
ici se pose un petit peu la question des
intelligences multiples dans le cadre
aussi de l'école parce qu'après dans la
deuxième partie de l'article ils vont un
petit peu se dire maintien commence à
match avec l'école or il faut savoir que
l'idée de vous proposer cet article là
est venue des changes que j'ai eues avec
les élèves de 6e en fait on est arrivé
je sais plus comment parce qu'on discute
beaucoup on est arrivé sur les
intelligences et sur les intelligences
multiples et
les élèves ont dit oui mais bon il ya
les intelligences multiples voilà il n'y
a pas que l'intelligence qui est mesurée
par les tests de qi et donc il était à
gramat cvo courant de cette théorie là
je leur ai dit j'ai lancé le pavé dans
la magie vous savez vous savez que c'est
une théorie qui n'a aucun fondement
scientifique pour l'instant est là s'en
est suivi un débat est donc je trouvais
ça intéressant de de vous montrer ceci
pour vous montrer que en effet ça reste
des hypothèses ces intelligences
multiples et donc c'est super
intéressant dans le sens où les
intelligences multiples mais on en parle
mais partout quoi alors ici on peut
aller voir sur youtube on va aller voir
sur youtube
on va taper intelligences multiples et
vous allez voir c'est assez dingue parce
que c'est présenté comme au mieux une
[Musique]
commande est une méthode de
développement personnel mais je veux
dire c'est pas du tout questionner quoi
après je vais vous dire si si vous
viviez bien que les intelligences
multiples et que ça vous aide à vous
construire il n'y a pas de souci mais
alors il faut pas dire que c'est une
théorie scientifique voilà les mêmes en
talent et en cliquant sur intelligences
multiples critiques mais on n'a aucune
critique si vous voulez alors ça c'est
bien je suis déjà bien référencés c'est
une bonne nouvelle mais voyez vous voyez
le nombre de publications sur les
intelligences multiples or ici voilà
pourquoi est-elle contesté c'est le
premier article qui en parlent mais les
autres n'en parle même pas et ici ce qui
est super intéressant c'est j'ai pas
regardé toute la vidéo mais regardez
dans le descriptif
avec l'arrivée des neurosciences dans le
domaine de l'éducation s'est aperçu que
l'intelligence et est bien plus complexe
que ce que l'on pouvait imaginer et si
l'on faisait fausse route depuis de
nombreuses années aujourd'hui il n'est
plus question de parler d'intelligence
ou singulier on parle plutôt
d'intelligence multiples fini le mythe
des tests mesurant le quotient
intellectuel les neurosciences ont pu
apporter une toute nouvelle vision de la
notion d'intelligence alors ça c'est
complètement du mensonge parce que les
intelligences multiples c'est une
théorie qui est déjà assez âgés ont jugé
puis la date on va on verra quand howard
gardner l'a proposé mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec nos sciences les intelligences
multiples puisque ses antérieurs et puis
ici on va pas aborder la question des
neurosciences mais je pense que les
neurosciences ne valide pas du tout la
théorie quoi mais ça si vous êtes plus
au courant que moi allez-y à ce niveau
là on pourra regarder ça plus tard dans
une autre vidéo est ce que les
neurosciences valide ou invalide
cette théorie des intelligences
multiples donc ça c'est inquiétant parce
que si vous voulez voilà on a une
théorie qui est
présenté comme une théorie scientifique
mais qui n'en est pas une
voilà ok juste une proposition
finalement c'est ce qu'on va voir dans
cet article ci alors l'article oh pardon
je vois que vous ne voyez plus de plus
que
le
le edge ne s'affiche plus hop voilà
c'est mieux
donc ici voilà on va avoir un article
qui est pas très empirique alors il faut
savoir qu'en sciences généralement quand
vous produisez un article scientifique
l'idée c'est d'avoir une proposition
théorique qui se base sur des lectures
scientifique ce qu'on appelle la revue
de la littérature ou l'état de l'art il
ya plusieurs noms pour dire ça ou
l'exploration vous allez vous basez sur
finalement ce que les autres ont déjà
trouvé avant vous pour formuler une
question de recherches originales
intéressantes pertinentes avec une bonne
problématique et puis vous allez
proposer des hypothèses que vous allez
vérifier par une observation alors ça
peut être une observation
quantitative
si vous utilisez des statistiques ou une
observation plus qualitatif
si vous allez par exemple observer sur
le terrain comme il ya quelques semaines
j'avais proposé un article sur la
structuration sociale du monde des sans
abri dans laquelle l'auteur aller sur le
terrain pendant huit mois
observé les communautés des sans abri de
sa ville de nancy je pense mais je ne
sais plus trop faire tourner sur la
vidéo donc ça c'est un peu le principe
de d'une démarche scientifique que vous
allez relaté dans un article
scientifique mais y'a des articles
scientifiques qui ne font pas du tout ça
mais ça veut pas dire qu'ils sont pas
scientifiques ils vont proposer une
synthèse alors si c'est plus une
synthèse quantitative on appellerait ça
une méta analyse ici voilà c'est
vraiment une synthèse de tout ce qui a
été dit sur cette théorie de warner qui
date de 1983 je vois la date ici donc
oui c'est pas du tout nouveau
il va nous proposer ils vont nous
proposer vraiment de faire le tour 1 la
revue de la littérature sur cette
question là
est ce que la théorie des intelligences
multiples et validées scientifiquement
voilà donc on a pas on n'a pas là que le
côté empirique habituels qu'on peut
retrouver dans un article et moi j'aime
bien proposer des articles avec une
visée empirique parce que
les élèves s'ils voulaient bon moi je
donne le cours au niveau secondaire
alors je sais que peut-être sur la
chaîne il ya des gens qui sont un autre
niveau qui écrit à ses vidéos et c'est
tant mieux j'espère ne pas dire trop de
bêtises mais en tout cas au niveau
secondaire parfois les élèves qu'on leur
parle de sciences sociales il imagine
que c'est du blabla que c'est des
théories voilà qu'on discute on débat et
que c'est pas de la science mais c'est
de la science dans le sens où on fait
des hypothèses et puis après on va les
vérifier alors évidemment il ya une
différence entre les sciences sociales
et les sciences de la nature où on peut
avoir un taux de prédiction peut-être
supérieur
mais quoique parfois en médecine ou en
biologie c'est plus compliqué donc
c'est vraiment ça qui est intéressant à
mon sens quand on fait cet exercice de
lecture ensemble d'un article
scientifique c'est que il ya cette
partie empirique et donc on ne la
retrouve pas ici mais voilà c'est un
parti pris sur cet objet si c'était plus
compliqué
allez on y va malheureusement pour tout
vous dire être transparent avec vous
j'avais tout surligner au fluo et j'ai
oublié de sauvegarder maccoppi le conte
1 est donc ici voilà je n'ai aucune n'a
notation alors que j'avais pris mon
temps de tout bien à noter pour préparer
ce stream m'enfin bon qu'est ce que vous
voulez c'est la vie c'est comme ça
alors c'est parti à la question
l'intelligence est l unique ou multiple
garner répond sans hésiter multiples il
n'est pas le premier à défendre la
nature diversifiée d'intelligence les
tenants de la proche factorielle
défendent l idée que l'intelligence
comporte un grand nombre de composantes
qu'on contrairement à spearman qui
proposait une approche unidimensionnelle
de l'intelligent symbolisée par g1 le
facteur g c'est l'intelligence général
si vous voulez le logiciel général ou
intelligent général voilà bon je ne
poursuivent pas le paragraphe 1 je vais
vraiment picorer dans dans l'article
sinon ça va être trop long et est pas
intéressant mais ce qui est super
important de souligner regardez c'est
que ici chaque fois qu'il ya une
affirmation qui est fait et bien elle
est sourcé et c'est bien là qu'est toute
la puissance de la science c'est que on
peut tout reconstruire finalement peu
tour vérifier il n'y a aucune
affirmation gratuite et souvent les
élèves parfois ils affirment des trucs
jardim c est gratuit c'est une
affirmation gratuite ou est-ce que tu le
vérifie alors ça évidemment ils me
répondent quasi inévitablement ah oui il
faut tout vérifier ben oui il faut tout
vérifier donc tout doit être source et
c'est le principe de faire de la science
alors c'est pas grave si vous êtes élève
du second vous êtes là pour apprendre
mais voilà si si on était un
scientifique ou si on est au niveau
universitaire il va falloir arriver à ce
niveau de précision et pour rappel à la
fin là vous avez la bibliographie 1
regardez ici la bibliographie et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait plaisir dans un
article scientifique c'est que regarder
ici on est à la page 18 sur 23 1 ici et
toi tu vois pas bien mais moi je vois
bien 18 sur 23 et bien en fait à cinq
pages après deux gratuits parce que
c'est que la bibliographie jdid gratuit
parce que quand on tapait un article de
40 pages on est bien content qu'ils
aient cinq pages de biographie en tout
cas à mon niveau puisque on fait ça en
dehors de nos activités principales donc
regarder ici vous avez toute la
bibliographie est par exemple s'il dit
ben voilà le clair que
2010 a bien voilà on à l'article ici le
clac 2010 ce qui nous permet de
retrouver dans
sur le net ou dans les revues
spécialisées de retrouver l'article
voilà ici c'est la revue canadienne de
l'éducation donc si tu sais où elle se
trouve tu vas voir directement dans ce
numéro là sinon tu cherches avec les
moteurs de recherche avec google scholar
par exemple donc voilà ça c'est le
principe d'un article scientifique et tu
vas voir qu'ici ils ont quand même fait
du fameux travail de lecture parce
qu'ils ont déjà une fameuse biographie
mot qui est à dieu
parce qu en fait voilà ils vont vraiment
faire une grosse grosse synthes même
temps sept buts
alors dans le cadre du débat sur
l'unicité donc le fait qu'on ait qu'une
seule intelligence qui finalement
jouerait sur le reste de tes capacités
ou des intelligences diverses cet
article présente les critiques dont a
fait l'objet cette théorie donc cette
théorie dewar garner de 1983 le texte
comprend quatre parties après avoir
donné un aperçu de la théorie des
intelligences multiples nous
présenterons neuf critiques susceptibles
de lui être adressées à l'agresser ce
toit agressif adressé ensuite nous nous
interrogerons sur son applicabilité dans
le domaine scolaire en conclusion nous
évoquons quelques raisons de son succès
donc c'est moi j'aime bien lire le début
l'introduction alors bizarrement dans un
bouquin je lis rarement l'introduction
mais dans un article je lis
l'introduction parce qu'en fait un
article je vais peut-être pas tout lire
un bouquin généralement si je me lance
lecture le bouquin c'est que j'ai envie
de le lire mais les articles tu en a
beaucoup tu dois en lire beaucoup un bon
moi je le fais comme ça on veut pas dire
en oublie parce que c'est pour faire
cette chaîne c'est pour animer cette
chaîne la société qu'est tout ça mais
quand tu es un chercheur que tu as
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire
il faut pas tout lire parce que sinon tu
vas être tu vas être submergé par la
quantité de matière et donc tu dois
absolument
sélectionner les lectures dans le sens
de livres que ce qui est intéressant est
pertinente dans sa recherche à toi est
donc ici par exemple tu vois directement
ce qui peut intéresser dans le plan ça
c'est le plan finalement ce paragraphe
là il représente le que je viens de dire
il représente le plan de la de la
recherche et donc si toi tu t'intéresses
que neuf critiques bah tu peux aller
directement la partie 9 critique si tu
t'intéresses si ta question de départ ou
de recherche c'est pourquoi une théorie
fausse connaît un succès et bien voilà
tu ici tu vas chercher plutôt la
dernière partie tu vois new man show ça
super intéressante a aussi l'abstract
l'abstract pour rappel c'est le résumé
ici il est pas en début d'article est à
la fin mais généralement tout articles
universitaires
comporte un abstract ça c'est sûr
attends je dois descendre c'est un peu
compliqué que mon multi-écrans ce qu'ils
passent sur l'autre écran
voilà hop
je vais avec les flèches du voile est
ici l'abstract
on peut le lire dans le débat sur
l'unicité où la multiplicité
intelligence garner prendre notamment
note nettement pardon position en faveur
des intelligences multiples son approche
soulève toutefois au moins neuf
critiques la confusion entre
l'intelligence et le talent une rigueur
scientifique insuffisante eh ouais
l'absence de réelle nouveauté le
caractère arbitraire et quitte à
utiliser les problèmes de
l'interdépendance des intelligences
multiples du réel statut des
intelligences multiples ignorance des
résultats des approches factorielle et
le refus de considérer les différences
entre groulx les groupes de la mesure
des intelligences multiples la validité
des applications des intelligences
multiples dans le milieu scolaire peut
également être mise en doute en
conclusion nous interrogeons sur le
succès sur les raisons du succès de la
théorie des intelligences multiples donc
je retrouve un petit peu ce qu'on avait
dit plus haut sauf que là c'est tata
même les deux facteurs qui sont déjà
donné qu voilà
alors on en revient à nos moutons
que j'utilise plus les raccourcis
clavier j'ai essayé de m'entraîner pour
passer d'une partie à l'autre du de
l'article si vous avez des conseils par
rapport aux raccourcis clavier que je
pourrais utiliser à les y attendait je
vois qu'il ya une question
je vais aller la chercher parce que je
suis avec plusieurs écrans
en fait ce matin c'était un peu la
galère j'ai dû
un peu
alors déjà en secondaire faire un peu
dit mr d'épistémologie des sciences
serait une bonne chose oui c'est sûr
alors on essaie d'en faire je pense
qu'il ya des profs qui essaient d'en
faire
notamment sciences sociales je sais pas
si dans les cours de sciences ont fait
beaucoup de d'épistémologie moment je
pense que c'est essentiellement en tout
cas dans le cours de sciences sociales
ca c est essentielle si tu as et grégory
une un témoignage par rapport à ça
n'hésite pas être plus précis dans le
commentaire c'est super intéressant
enfin bon ça m'aiderait déjà beaucoup
pour mes cours à moi de savoir ce qu'ils
puissent qui peut être fait et toi tu
parles à quel niveau toi tu es à quel
niveau tu es tu es déjà dans le dans le
dans les sciences sociales où tu es
encore dans le secondaire puisque voilà
je te connais pas donc ça serait
peut-être intéressant de le préciser
mais c'est clair c'est clair moi je
pense que alors c'est un avis personnel
si aujourd'hui tu as une telle défiance
par rapport à la science telle défiance
par rapport aux théories dites
officielles mais qui sont les théories
scientifiques 1 avec une remise en
question avec des théories du complot
avec le créationnisme qui s'étend aux
états unis il ya des universités belges
qui reçoivent de la part de certaines
universités bon on appelle ça
universités mais est ce que ce sont
vraiment des universités en tout cas
d'organisations américaines des déprécie
de créationnisme si vous voulez on en
est là c'est pas gagné pour la science
c'est pas du tout gagné mais je pense
que voilà les gens ne voient pas c'est
quoi la science en fait ils ne savent
pas c'est quoi et donc je suis d'accord
super g super d'accord avec toi grégory
ainsi si déjà on leur expliquait un peu
mieux ce qu'est la science
on ferait un grand pas même mais on peut
aller même plus loin
le clivage qui peut y avoir entre les
sciences humaines les sciences sociales
les sciences naturelles c'est
hallucinant que tata plein de physiciens
ou enfin c'est peut-être une
représentation que j'aime et je pense
qu'elle est quand même relativement vrai
qui décrit les sciences sociales les
sciences humaines parce que voilà
simplement ils ne les connaissent pas
quoi donc moi je pense qu'il faudrait
aussi aller plus loin dans la
connaissance des différentes sciences
des différentes méthodologies qui sont
possibles alors moi je met pas sur le
même pied les sciences sociales et les
sciences naturelles elles font pas
exactement la même chose dans le sens du
résultat mais en termes de méthode il ya
des méthodes qui sont quand même
relativement commune est donc un cours
d'épistémologie aussi qu'ils parleraient
à la fois des sciences sociales à la
fois des sciences naturelles mais de
manière vraiment neutre parce que
finalement parfois c'est à un physicien
qui donne un cours d'épistémologie ou
quelqu'un qui a plus une si celle-ci
sensibilité dans ce moule non ce côté là
eh bien il va finalement
défendre un petit peu les sciences
naturelles et al'inverse quelqu'un qui a
fait les sciences sociales défendrait
les sciences sociales donc il faudra
avoir quelque chose de très très mature
de très adulte mais voilà on est on est
pas prêt de l'avoir parce que dans le
secondaire finalement en tout cas en
belgique alors je sais pas si toi tu es
en belgique ou en france mais en
belgique voilà c'est assez compliqué
déjà comme ça pour vous donner nos
propres cours pour donner notre propre
cour et faire vraiment des choses
intéressantes avec les élèves c'est déjà
compliqué alors si tu rajoutes en plus
des volets épistémologique d un cours
d'épistémologie voile à l'école on
demande déjà tellement de choses à
l'école enfin voilà ça c'est un débat
qui est vraiment très très général je
vois que tu tu as un produit
voiture fait des études de sociologie
bah oui donc d'un recul par rapport à la
pratique des sciences sociales mais moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec toi
tout à fait d'accord avec toi bon on
revient sur notre article n'hésitez pas
c'est vraiment c'est pour ça que je fais
des directs c'est pour avoir des
échanges comme ceci pour qu'on puisse
réfléchir aussi ensemble à comment faire
des sciences sociales c'est ça qui est
qui est intéressant alors selon garner
pour attribuer à une compétence statut
d' intelligence elle devrait satisfaire
plus ou moins oui critères et voilà les
critères je vais pas les lire un ton
l'article ici est en
consultation libre il est dans le
descriptif de la vidéo sur youtube sur
twitch je ne sais pas mettre les
informations mais sur youtube si vous
êtes dans le descriptif vous allez
retrouver le lien
donc vous pouvez tout lire mais si tu
veux plus loin on va le dire j'anticipe
déjà le problème c'est qu'avec ses ouïes
critères gardner ne va pas les appliquer
systématiquement aux différentes
intelligence qu'il signale qu'il pointe
généralement dans un article
scientifique si tu dis qu'il ya oui
critères tu vas les appliquer pour les
huit intelligence qu'après tu va définir
mais lui le fait pas donc c'est déjà un
problème parce qu'il propose une
méthodologie il propose une base et
finalement il ne s'y tient pas quoi
quelque part
donc ça c'est un premier un premier
problème
alors grégory thil dit sur youtube alors
oui si vous êtes sur twitter ou si vous
êtes sur youtube vous pouvez intervenir
j'ai mis toute façon les deux chat vous
voyez les deux chat ici à l'écran donc
n'hésitez pas un messie sur youtube qui
nous dit oui la scientificité est
différente selon la discipline si on
regarde la tour par exemple on a une
déconstruction des sciences naturelles
j'apprécie comment ces travaux montrent
la dimension sociale de la recherche
scientifique l'établissement des
théories n'est pas une production pure
des expériences oui c'est aussi
intéressant
c'est aussi intéressant que finalement
tu as une manière aussi de raconter
alors je re traduit peut-être mal ce que
tu dis mais de raconter finalement ton
expérience avec certains biais peut-être
des billets parfois idéologique de
l'idéologie dans laquelle on se situe
soi même
c'est tout à fait intéressant et situe à
grégory un article de la tour
sur ce thème tu peux éventuellement le m
ça pourrait être une proposition pour
une prochaine lecture qu'on ferait
ensemble ça n'hésite pas
alors ici voyez-y les critiques
adressées à la théorie des intelligences
multiples donc voilà on a brièvement
parlé des intelligences multiples si
vous ne savez pas c'est quoi les
intelligences multiples ça on peut le
parcourir ensemble plus loin ici un
tableau qui nous résume ces différentes
intelligence on aurait l'intelligence
linguistique musicale logico
mathématique spatiale kinesthésique
interpersonnelles intra personnel
naturaliste et existentielle voilà c'est
un trouve un truc qu'on retrouve très
très couramment dans les écoles ou dans
les formations de développement
personnel donc à chaque fois ce sont des
habiletés et plus loin dans l'article on
va nous dire que finalement les
définitions qui sont donnés ici sont un
peu tautologique c'est à dire qu'elles
sont circulaires sont des définitions
circulaire qu'est ce que l'intelligence
logico mathématique c'est une
intelligence foutu et où tu as de la
logique et de la mathématique voilà en
fait tu n'as rien défini si tu veux
qu'est ce que l'intelligence
linguistique c'est une habileté liés à
la linguistique à issy dit langage mais
je vais je force le trait pour que vous
compreniez ce qu'est une définition
circulaire
donc en fait voilà on n'avance pas d'un
iota avec ses différentes intelligence
quoi alors peut-être que dans les
publications de garner on est un peu
plus précis en tout cas les auteurs ici
de cet article ne
ne vont pas plus loin et critiques un
petit peu cette façon de définir les
différentes intelligence
et vous voyez que les critiques
adressées à cette théorie sont
nombreuses je vais pas passer
tout en revue et l'ours qui est
intéressant c'est que garner lui-même a
répondu à certains à certaines critiques
dont il ya vraiment un dialogue
scientifique qui s'est établie qui
serait vraiment très intéressant d'aller
d'aller comment dire parcourir mais on
le fera pas dans le cadre cette
recherche de cette pub de cette
présentation aujourd'hui ce que ça
serait beaucoup trop longs évidemment et
je ne le ferai pas non plus parce que je
n'ai pas le temps forcément de le faire
mais ça devrait être très intéressant
alors même si le modèle de garner repose
sur des dimensions du fonctionnement
intellectuel pour la plupart négligé par
les tests de quotient intellectuel
traditionnels cela ne suffit pas pour
autant que nous sommes en présence d'un
telligent ans différentes donc est-ce
que ça c'est la première critique qu'on
fait c'est que à super merci grégory
c'est que est-ce que garner ne confonds
pas tout simplement ce qu'est
l'intelligence de simplement un talent
et un talent en janvier un petit peu je
fais un lien avec ce que tu dis grégory
mais ce talent pour être lui-même
déconstruit
par les sciences sociales donc
c'est déjà une première grande question
parce qu'en fait le problème de la faim
le travail de garner c22 de remettre en
question tous ces tests d'intelligence
puisque dans notre société on aurait
surtout l'intelligence linguistique et
logico mathématique qui seraient mises
en avant finalement et qu'ils seraient
évalués par les tests de qi
traditionnels et qui pourrait
s'assimiler à quelque part au facteur g
dont on a parlé un peu plus haut et lui
dit mais c'est plus compliqué que ça
parce qu'il ya plusieurs intelligence le
deuxième problème a trait à l'éventuelle
prolifération d intelligence bah oui ici
lendemain 8 mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas inventé une énième
intelligence j'ai pas une intelligence
mécanique par exemple de comprendre les
systèmes mécaniques ou une indigence
informatique peut-être que c'est un peu
différent d'une intelligence logico
mathématique l'âge et invente un des
intelligences qu'on pourrait trouver
mais c'est c'est un peu ça la question
jusqu'où on peut s'arrêter dans dans les
différents intelligence et d'ailleurs
garner lui-même rajoute des
intelligences au fur et à mesure de ses
publications
voilà ça pousse ça pose aussi une
question jusqu'où s'arrêter dans les
intelligences à partir du moment où ça
correspondrait aux différents critères
qui nous a donné troisième problème
concernant le recoupement des notion
d'intelligence et de talent c'est bien
connu de substantielles particularité
différencie les individus dans les
champs d'activités humaines qu'on
appelle traditionnellement talent ou
dons mais s'agit-il pour autant
d'intelligence même s'il admet avoir
abusé du terme intelligents sont
l'appliquant à des domaines qu'ils
eussent probablement mérité une autre
terminologie gerner maintient que la
distinction entre talent et une
intelligence traduit un bien culturel en
faveur de la logique et du langage au
détriment d'autres capacités
si vous voulez appeler l'ont tous
talents ou intelligence donc là il ya
aussi un problème de définition toujours
avec ces questions de talent et
d'intelligence qui n'est pas réellement
fait et c'est intéressant parce que nous
aussi on nous précise aussi que garner
lui-même parfois bien se corriger sur sa
première sur sa première son premier jet
ou sur sa théorie plus globale mais
cette correction n'est pas prise en
compte forcément par les gens qui
reprennent après comme on l'a vu sur
youtube ces différentes intelligence
quatrièmement la conception de gerner
dégage une saveur politique on peut
certes déploré mêmes dénoncé les
inégalités céréales des individus
talentueux dans deux domaines autres que
ceux traditionnellement mesurée par les
tests de qi par exemple certaines
vedettes du monde musical cumul des
salaires exorbitants alors que des
individus beaucoup plus talentueux
doivent souvent se contenter de mes
revenus or on ne retrouve pas d'aidé car
économique aussi prononcé entre les
individus de qi très élevé et ceux de qi
élevé ou moyen d'en déplaise à garner on
ne résoudra pas le problème de la
reconnaissance sociale en implants
intelligence des talents donc garnat ils
essaient aussi c'est moi c'est comme ça
que je le comprends il a aussi une visée
si vous voulez sociétale ou sociale de
faire accepter plus les différences ou
de devoir de jouer si vous voulez avec
ce concept d'égalité sociale
parce que c'est vrai c'est pas parce que
tu es un gros qi que tu vas bien réussir
ta vie que tu vas avoir un succès social
et à l'école je dire non plus quoi donc
il essaie peut-être de redonner de la
cohérence à tout ça parce que c'est le
rôle d'un scientifique de redonner de la
cohérence à ce à la société je ne pense
pas quoi enfin les deux exemples
suivants montrent que l'insistance de
garner a accordé le statut d'
intelligence à de simples talent peut
donner lieu à des débordements et
engendrait des faux espoirs le premier
exemple concerne l'intelligence
kinesthésique et le second
l'intelligence musicale dans le cas de
l'intelligence kinesthésique garner
considère que quelques quelle qu'en soit
la raison le fait qu'un maître zen
puisse casser des briques à mains nues
ou marcher sur des braises plus
globalement la conviction qu'ils
puissent traduire une intention
directement en action doit nous
émerveiller même si cela défie
l'explication scientifique courante et
ça c'est faux en fait parce qu'on sait
que marcher sur les braises il ya des
facteurs physiques qui interviennent
comme le fait que la cendre elles
viennent isoler la chaleur de la base et
que si tu va très vite finalement c'est
comme marcher sur du sable brûlant
soleil estime donc finalement l'exemple
qu'il donne ça ne prouve rien et puis ce
n'est qu'un exemple
donc c'est un peu ça aussi le problème
de garner c'est que au niveau de ses
justifications c'est un peu
c'est un peu critiquable comme un bouc
estiot nabeul en tout cas quoi
voilà c'est ce qu'on explique ici dans
le second cas dans le second cas il ya
l'effet mozart si vous voulez vous et
couturiers mozart enfin certains
morceaux voilà la sonate k 448 de moser
vous augmente auriez votre raisonnement
spatial ça c'est un neuro mythe qui a
été démonté à plusieurs reprises et on
montre que garner finalement quand il
fait ses expériences ou quand il se base
sur certaines expériences ne tient pas
compte de ses capacités avant dont tu
veux pas il fait pas forcément un
prétexte pour évaluer les capacités
alors tu vas prendre un échantillon
d'individus
pour leur faire passer une expérience tu
vas leur faire écouter mozart et puis tu
vas remarquer que ceux chez qui t'a fait
écouter mozart font de meilleures
performances sur certains tests post
écoute mais t'as pas tester s'il faisait
déjà des meilleurs tests avant de
peut-être qu'ils étaient juste meilleur
avant donc ça c'est des erreurs
méthodologiques que ici gardner fait
mais voilà je pense que même les élèves
de qui débutent les sciences sociales
comprendrais très très vite qu'il faut
faire un prétexte pour voir s'il ya un
delta entre le pré test et le post est
alors grande question ici est ce que
finalement cette théorie des
intelligences multiples c'est une
théorie scientifique même si elle fait
appel entre autres aux sciences
neurologiques et à l'anthropologie tout
en s'appuyant sur des biographies la
théorie des intelligences multiples
demeurent anecdotiques et offre au
lecteur une opinion bien articuler
plutôt qu'une théorie scientifique au
sens strict faute précisément d'un
ensemble de construit susceptibles
d'expliquer les performances
intellectuelles donc en fait on ne vit
ici que l'inter la théorie des
intelligences multiples de warner c'est
plutôt un essai c'est un essai mais avec
aucune aucune vérification au pays
alors évidemment ce qui a été
intéressant et kerner c'est qu'il a fait
bouger un petit peu les lignes
et ça on voit pas dire que la théorie
est totalement
comment dire inutiles elle a pu être
utile notamment pour relancer certains
débats ça c'est sûr et puis elle peut
avoir une utilité au sein des salles de
classe ou sur youtube ou si comme on l'a
vu je dirais peut être utile pour le
grand public à certains égards mais on
ne peut pas dire que c'est une théorie
scientifique
alors voilà c'est ce que je disais au
niveau des critères finalement même sur
les choix des critères qui permet de
dire qu'on est face à une intelligence
ou pas c'est pas tout à fait net
l'application des ouïes critères comme
je voulais dit il ne l'a pas fait on se
serait attendu à ce que garner montre en
quoi les ouïes critères s'appliquent à
chacune des neuf intelligence par
exemple une table à double entrée aurait
permis de voir combien de critères
rencontre les intelligences vous voyez
la structure du tableau un tableau
voyage pourrait les différents critères
sur les rangées et dans les colonnes les
différentes intelligence et de voir
tient une petite application une petite
analyse pour chacun un clic des critères
ça c'est un truc que je pourrais
demander même aux élèves parce que c'est
des choses comme ça qu'on veut avoir des
choses qui montre et qui prouve certain
moment que ce que tu affirmes est vrai
alors
warner lui il va soutenir que c'est
intelligent ce sont sont autonomes les
unes des autres sont indépendantes mais
dès qu'on fait des textes des tests dès
qu'il ya des publications actuelles qui
parle d intelligence on se rend compte
que tout est plus ou moins liés et qu'en
tout cas il ya quand même des
intelligences qui sont plus universel
est plus importante c'est la logique aux
mathématiques et la linguistique alors
que garner dit non c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment indépendant et autonome mais tu
vois que ta capacité a par exemple
réalisé la musique ça tient fort aussi
de la capacité à manier la logique à
manier la langue
donc ça c'est aussi intéressant c'est ce
débat autonomie ou hétéronomie des
différentes intelligence quoi
et c'est ça arrive à la question
finalement est ce que les neuf
intelligents sont vraiment le même
statut c'est ce que je disais que la
prépondérance quand même de
l'intelligence logico mathématique et
linguistique la théorie des
intelligences multiples a été élaboré et
est a été élaboré par don pour contrer
la suprématie des conceptions classiques
de l'intelligence trop exclusivement
centrée sur les aspects verbaux logico
mathématique et même spatiaux à moins de
modifier la société concédé le même
statut ou neuf formes intelligence ne
correspond pas à la réalité et ce pour
au moins deux raisons la première
premièrement si les intelligences
verbale et logico mathématique sont à
l'oeuvre dans presque tous les secteurs
de l'activité humaine ce n'est pas le
cas des autres formes d'intelligence par
exemple si l'intelligence logico
mathématique ne saurait faire défaut aux
musiciens la compétence musicale n'est
pas indispensable au raisonnement
logique aux mathématiques deuxièmement
garner reconnaît lui-même le statut
privilégié des intelligences
linguistique et logico mathématique
la première admet-il donc c'est gerner
lui-même qui le dit et la compétence
intellectuelle la plus largement et la
plus démocratiquement partagés au sein
de l'espèce humaine qui plus est garner
attache beaucoup d'importance au fait
qu'une intelligence doit pouvoir prendre
forme dans un système de symbole ce qui
est le cas pour au moins 5 intelligence
donc pour lui doit pouvoir l'être
traduire quelque part
or il est difficile d'admettre que les
intelligences autre que verbale puisse
s'exercer adéquatement sans recours au
langage lorsqu'elles sont parvenus à
leur plein développement comment en
effet communiqué des savoirs et de
savoir-faire musicaux mathématiques
picturaux kinesthésique qu'ils aient
saisi que je n'ai pas dit c'est tout ce
qui est lié au corps incapacité à vous
mouvoir à
utiliser votre corps dans l'espace ou
relationnels sans utiliser le langage
donc tu as toujours le langage qui est
qui revient comme un méta intelligence
quelque part à la limite on pourrait
même conclure qu'il n'ya pas
d'intelligence sans langage et donc du
coup est ce que tu peux considérer que
l'intelligence la linguistique est une
intelligence comme l'intelligence
musicale alors que l est au dessus si tu
es donc ça revient un petit peu à cette
question à ce débat entre intelligence
et talent à ce que simplement le fait de
vous pouvoir être un bon musicien c'est
pas juste un talent qui pourraient être
construits et socialement je le rappelle
en ce qui concerne l'intelligence logico
mathématique est la deuxième grande
intelligence qui est mise en évidence
dans nos sociétés ou en tout cas
valorisant société l'aveu est encore
plus marquée maniant le rasoir d'occam
alors rasoir de came c'est un processus
de réflexion dans lequel tu vas aller
toujours sur des hypothèses qui
paraissent les plus faciles les plus
évidentes le plus simple par rapport à
des hypothèses compliqué par exemple si
un élève arrive en retard en classe tu
va penser que c'est peut-être parce
qu'il a raté le bus plutôt que parce que
c'est il a été enlevé par un gang
mafieux new yorkais tu vois tu vas plus
tôt sans utiliser l'hypothèse la plus la
plus simple la plus comment dire la plus
évidente
donc on pourrait conclure que l'attitude
logico mathématique n'est pas un système
pure et autonomes comme les autres
étudier ici et ne devrait peut-être pas
être considérée comme une seule
intelligence mais comme une sorte de
supra intelligence ou d'intelligence
plus générale après tout la plupart des
signes d'une intelligence autonomes se
trouve dans le cadre de la pensée logico
mathématique et c'est garner lui-même
qui le dit hein ce constat est en
quelque sorte confirmé par le fait que
l'une des trois seules écoles
secondaires de montréal qui affichait un
taux de réussite mathématiques
supérieures à 80 % en 1997 soit une
école de danse qui accueille les enfants
les plus performants au plan académique
donc voilà donc d'une école de danse ta
les gens qui sont super calé en
intelligence logico mathématique fin
super calé c'est pas le bon mot mais qui
ont une intelligence logico mathématique
supérieur quoi donc c'est super
intéressant et tu vois que quand même
cette intelligence l'aller présente chez
tous ceux qui ont un talent ailleurs des
enseignants qui mettrait sur pied une
école de danse dans la perspective de
garner privilégierait l'intelligence
corporelle même si une bonne performance
académique constitue un important
critère de réussite
autrement dit est privé de savoir-faire
musicaux sportifs n'est pas une
limitation majeur tandis qu'eads privé
d'habileté de linguistique et logico
mathématique joue sérieusement sur
l'adaptation psychosocial d'un individu
vouloir à tous crins un statut identique
pour toutes les intelligences et il me
semble tenir une position plus
idéologique que scientifique et c'est là
qu'on peut se poser comme question c'est
la question poser est-ce que garner ne
fait pas de l'idéologie de l'idéologie
égalitaire parce que voilà tu remets un
peu les pendules à l'heure
auprès des individus qui auraient de
mauvais tests de qi par exemple en leur
disant oui mais tu sais il ya d'autres
intelligences quelque part tu vois ça un
petit peu une vocation à à émanciper les
personnes à leur donner l'occasion de
dire bah oui je suis pas je suis pas
débile et finalement remettre les
pendules à l'heure ce niveau là quoi
voilà ça moi je pense que ça l'est un
petit peu coincé cette théorie et quand
tu vois les gens qu'ils appliquent dans
les écoles c'est souvent voilà pour
aider les élèves qui qui s'en sortent
pas donc ça a des vertus 1 c'est une
théorie qui a des vertus je veux dire
sociale mais est ce que c'est une
théorie scientifique c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser
bon le problème de garner cecchini un
petit peu ce facteur g qui serait cette
méga l'intelligence quelque part un qui
a déjà été fortement travaillé donc
garner en fait il fait abstraction de
toute une partie
du construit de la science ce qui est
pas à faire puisque généralement quand
tu fais une recherche tu dois partir de
ce qui existe
alors les différences entre groupes la
théorie des intelligences multiples
passe complètement sous silence les
comparaisons homme-femme et
interethnique sous prétexte que c'est
une question potentiellement explosif
est que les distinctions entre groupes
déjà mise en évidence ont été exploitées
à des fins politiques douteuses donc ça
c'est garner qui le dit et donc il va
pas investiguer tout ce tout cet aspect
là de la chose parce qu'ils disent et
c'est dangereux mais attends fermât
science tu t'en fous de ce qui est
dangereuse qui est pas dangereux
instincts mans on a quand même fait des
recherches sur l'atome même si on savait
que c'était potentiellement dangereux
informant la science alors je sais que
la science sans conscience ça ne se fait
pas face et c'est discutable mais a
certainement voilà tu dois quand même
investiguer ces questions là
les mesures des intelligences multiples
alors là on passe sur le côté empirique
comment faire pour mesurer les
intelligences multiples et on nous dit
ici directement dans le titre que c'est
un raté donc en fait on n'a jamais
réellement pu mesurer les intelligences
multiples et je vais te résumer un petit
peu ce qui est dit ici parce que tu vois
ici il ya pas mal de choses qui sont
écrites je peux pas tout lire ça on peut
peut-être lire
cet encadré là si tu veux le bernard il
dit les intelligences elles doivent se
mesurer dans un contexte
approprié dans le sens où si tu veut
mesurer l'intelligence musicale de
quelqu'un tu dois le regarder évoluer
dans son univers musical quelque part tu
vois tu peux pas faire des tests
décontextualisés tu peux pas faire des
tests oubliée par le biais d'un
questionnaire par exemple
et donc tu dois tout le temps aller vers
une observation mais le problème quand
tu fais ça c'est que à ce moment là tu
restes sur une approche qualitative
alors que garner à son amant parlent
tous de choses quantitatif mais tu
pourrais rester que sur du qualitatif ce
que tu peux pas standardisé
l'observation chaque observation tu va
réaliser va être dans un contexte
particulier
est d'autant plus tu es ce que tu
mesures vraiment l'intelligence parce
que si tu observes un musicien dans son
contexte
deux musiciens mais forcément il a des
habitudes il a aussi des motivations
qu'il n'aurait peut-être pas quand tu
quand tu mesures le cuit avec un texte
un test de qi était une mesure vraiment
l'intelligence mais les gens s qui sont
motivés ou pas bon oui sont peut-être un
peu motivés à passer le test mais c'est
pas le contexte qui va vraiment les
motiver et tandis que quand tu quand tu
regardes peut-être un sportif faire son
sport et donc la mesure et son
intelligence kinesthésique mais voilà il
est motivé par son sport parce que c'est
quelque chose qui connaît alors est-ce
que tu mesures plus d'autre chose que
son intelligence c'est la question quoi
voilà ça ça manque aussi de pertinence
et de
deux puissances empirique si tu veux
cette théorie parce qu'elle est allée
jamais vraiment mesuré par des tests
standardisés
alors on peut lire ce petit encadrait
pour évaluer les connaissances en
français lors de l'examen d'entrée à
harvard en suggéra la rédaction d'un
essai sur une période de trois heures
certains proposèrent d'évaluer les mêmes
connaissances à l'aide d'un
questionnaire standardisé à choix
multiple d'une durée d'une heure donc là
c'est l'opposition si tu veux entre une
activité vraiment contextualiser laisser
voilà de trois heures une rédaction
complète et un test standardisé qui va
vraiment mesurer les choses de manière
très précise
malgré un coefficient de corrélation de
points 90 donc ça veut dire que entre
les deux résultats finalement ce qu'ils
vont réussir laisser vont réussir le
test
d'une heure et inversement ce qui
réussit ce test d'une heure réussissent
laissait donc on a vraiment une liaison
entre les deux une corrélation entre les
deux épreuves et donc en fait tu peut
substituer l'une à l'autre malgré un
coefficient de corrélation de 0,90 entre
les deux instruments des membres du
comité d'admission continuèrent à
s'objecter de à l'utilisation des
questionnaires sous prétexte qu'un tel
type d'instrument ne pourrez évaluer
réellement les connaissances en français
une telle position n'est pas sans
rappeler la proposition de gerner
d'échelonner les évaluations des
intelligents sur longue période au lieu
d'utiliser les tests disponibles
mesurant les mêmes habiletés
quelles que soient les raisons qui ont
motivé les résistants elle ne semble pas
relever de l'attitude scientifique et
c'est un petit peu le problème de garner
qui est refuse d'utilisation des tests
standardisés et qui lui veut revenir des
observations dans un certain contexte et
c'est préciser ici et je ne l'avais pas
dit a vraiment à une période de temps
très très longue
mais ça pose vraiment des questions
méthodologiques du coucou
alors maintenant on passe sur l'aspect
applications dans le contexte scolaire
je fais une petite pause je vais voir un
petit peu si
il ya toujours des spectateurs dans ce
live ça ne change rien ça me permet
juste un peu d'en adapter aussi les
prochains life alors je vois qu'on est
il ya une personne sur twitter c'est
sympa parce que le dernier live du
dimanche sur twitter avait eu personne
est alors sur sur facebook sur youtube
par dont vous êtes 7 c'est quand même
sympa un cd bon c'est des bons chiffres
pour moi dans le sens où voilà quoi si
on a une dizaine moi ça me pousse à
continuer parce que si tous les
dimanches matins je me lève où je me
couche tard pour pour zéro personne
c'est un peu plus embêtant mais enfin
après a aussi des personnes qui
regardent régulièrement en rediffusion
donc c'est super sympa mais je suis
vraiment très content si si ça vous
intéresse comme contenu
voilà parce que ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose de gagner on nous fait
quand même des trucs de niche 6 6 1
alors dans le à l'école comment ça se
passe ces intelligences multiples et
professionnels du monde de l'éducation
se laisse facilement convaincre de la
valeur des nouvelles théories touchant
les réalités qu'ils écopent concerne
cet égard les propositions de garner ou
de quoi réjouir enfin l'intelligence
unique reçoit un coup de massue comme on
est souvent prêt à passer aux
applications indépendamment des appuis
scientifique l'ampleur de la déception
subséquente des enseignants est souvent
proportionnelle à l'engouement des
promoteurs oui parce qu'après ça
débouche parfois sur sur pas grand-chose
coin quand applique des nouveaux des
nouveautés à l'école tout le monde est
enthousiaste
ou alors certains soient enthousiastes
les innovateurs sont enthousiastes et
puis fit finalement les résultats sont
pas toujours là quoi surtout si si c'est
pas appuyer scientifiquement ainsi
certains projets ddea éducative ne tarde
il ne tarde t-il pas à se mettre en
place dont au premier chef ceux de
guerlain à ses colères le projet spectre
basé sur la théorie des intelligences
multiples en maternelle donc voilà on a
une théorie qui est pas scientifiquement
irréfutable n'ai pas été à 100 %
scientifiquement et elle fait déjà des
effets dans le monde scolaire ça pose
des questions quand même sur comment
l'école et piloter et comment elle prend
les choses en compte mais je veux dire
y'a pas que le monde scolaire parce que
quand tu l'as vu comme tu l'as vu sur
youtube il ya plein de vidéos qui vont
faire la publicité des intelligences
multiples en la faisant passer pour une
théorie scientifique alors qu'elle ne
l'est pas et moi encore une fois j'ai
aucun problème avec la théorie des
intelligences multiples si tu dis que
c'est une proposition si tu dis que
c'est pas ça pas été vérifiée tu vois au
début de ta vidéo tu dis attention cette
théorie si elle est contestée encore
scientifiquement mais je suis sûr qu'on
peut faire un relevé alors voilà après
je sais jamais qu'une hypothèse que je
fais ici mais je suis sûr que tu peux
faire un relevé sur youtube de comment
on parle des intelligences multiples ça
serait d'ailleurs une petite recherche à
faire on pourrait j'en ai déjà gelé déjà
évoquées on pourrait sur cette chaîne
youtube faire finalement un mini
laboratoire de recherche de sciences
sociales qui s'intéresserait
principalement à youtube mais ici on
pourrait le faire tient à ce que les
théories des intelligences multiples
telles qu'exposées sur youtube sont
exposés comme des théories scientifiques
ou son
considérés comme des des propositions ça
serait intéressant
alors voilà je vais pas passer en revue
ici tout ce qui est fait dans les écoles
toutes ces initiatives ont développé le
programme scolaire outils dont on est
sûr des dévises et égalitaire finalement
quand tu introduis les intelligences
multiples à l'école c'est pour essayer
de ramener plus d'égalité 1
voilà et ici on précise aussi que même
les recommandations suggérées par gerner
donc ici là on vise la pratique hein
comment est-ce qu'on commente est ce
qu'on peut améliorer la pratique des
praticiens bien même ces propositions
sont très vagues
voilà donc là tu pourra lire si ça
t'intéresse alors conclusion ça on va
lire toute la conclusion parce que la
conclusion c'est souvent ce qui est le
plus intéressant dans un article
scientifique comme je le dis aux élèves
si tu n'as pas le temps de lire tout
l'article parce que voilà ici tu as 23
pages donc t'as pas forcément le temps
de tout lire contente toi de 1
l'abstract pour voir si c'est vraiment
ça qui t'intéresse puis tu vas picorer
dans le texte les et les partis qui
t'intéresse vraiment et puis tu termines
en lisant tout la conclusion qui est pas
forcément très longs ou parfois la
discussion parfois on appelait ça la
discussion
et tu auras vraiment les éléments
essentiels du texte et or a lu le texte
de manière beaucoup plus rapide après si
le texte intéresse vraiment l'itu le
texte quoi si je te dis ça pour
sélectionner ton texte ben voila tu peux
te contenter dans un premier temps d'une
lecture un peu comme ça en diagonale
avec la conclusion en point d'orgue
dès sa publication frames of mind a été
sévèrement critiquée par la communauté
scientifique tout en soulevant
l'enthousiasmé dans les milieux de
l'éducation une telle réaction positif
surprend d'autant plus que garner
d'autant plus
garner pardon que son livre ne visait
pas particulièrement ce lectorat donc en
fait bernard il a été un peu dépassé par
sa théorie quoi elle a été plus vite que
lui depuis la théorie des intelligences
multiples s'est propagé sur les cinq
continents le titre de l ouvrage de
thiennes maurane et gartner multiples
intelligence and the world traduit bien
cette vogue au moins trois raisons sont
susceptibles d'expliquer un tel succès
premièrement frames of mind a tout pour
séduire écrit dans un style littéraire
et journalistique plutôt que
scientifique l'ouvragé captivant et
accessible à tout lecteur instruits donc
tu as un truc un peu sexy si tu me
permet l'expression les ouvrages de
garner sont à cet égard une véritable
leçon de communication la beauté du
modèle et son caractère humaniste
séduisent les tenants de l'éducation et
suscite une dose d'espoir chez les
enseignants aux prises avec de plus en
plus d'enfants présentant des
difficultés scolaires ceux ci espèrent
en effet contrer les échecs scolaires
des élèves moins performants en matière
logico mathématique et linguistique en
considérant d'autre forme d'intelligence
et ça me fait penser à une autre idée de
recherche ce qu'on pourrait faire c'est
aussi y tient est-ce que dans le monde
de l'enseignement ou dans le monde de
l'entreprise ou le monde de la formation
en général ou sur youtube tu as d'autres
comme sa théorie un peu contesté
scientifiquement ou un peu beaucoup qui
ont eu un succès considérable et tu
pourrais voir qui est ce qu'il ya des
règles qui font est ce qu'il ya des
invariants par rapport à ces différentes
théories est-ce que des théories qui se
diffusent sans être terrifiant
scientifiquement ont finalement les
mêmes caractéristiques par exemple ce
style vraiment attractif de l'article
qui permet d'être bien compris par tout
le monde quoi tu vois ça serait vraiment
intéressant ça fait aussi l'écho
d'un mondial de dinde une lecture que
j'ai fait ici sur goffman goffman nous
dit un gouffre c'est un très célèbre
sociologue américain goffman nous dit si
tu es capable de bien communiquer
peut-être que tu n'es pas bien capable
de bien travailler au niveau
scientifique enfin il le dit autrement
mais en fait il veut dire que
généralement quand arrive à avoir une
bonne communication t t'es peut-être un
moins bon chercheur
et quand tu es un bon chercheur parfois
des thèmes plus - à l'est sur ta
communication mais c'est valable dans
tous les tous les domaines voilà
quelqu'un qui communique bien finalement
c'est un bon communicant il a des
compétences en tant que communicant mais
ce qu'il
les mêmes compétences en termes de
l'objet qu'il communique finalement tu
vois donc c'est aussi intéressant c'est
cette relation entre l'écrit et le
l'objet d'études c'est aussi une
réflexion qu'on peut se faire par
rapport à beaulieu qui lui a à l'opposé
un style vraiment rébarbatif
c'est vraiment chiant lire en tout cas
quand on commence après on prend on
prend finalement au bout c'est comme
tout et puis bon dieu voilà il ya une
théorie vraiment très profonde derrière
quoi quelque part donc c'est ça c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est le rapport et
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure avec grégory mais finalement
c'est ce rapport entre la roche l'objet
de la recherche je rajoute l'objet
l'objet de la recherche la recherche et
la communication de la recherche 1 on a
différents niveaux avec
différents des ajustements si je puis
dire entre ces différents niveaux quoi
ça c'est assez intéressant mais tout est
intéressant
deuxièmement il faut dire que
l'intelligence fait partie des sujets
brûlants dans l'univers des sciences
remettre en question les moyens
traditionnels de la mesure et donne une
certaine légitimité aux débats que la
taxe soit justifié ou non lorsqu'elle
s'inscrit dans l'air du temps il suffit
qu'elle touche des cordes sensibles pour
entraîner l'adhésion peu importe le bien
fondé des arguments et voilà l'ont
toujours aussi une autre question qui
est celle de l'idéologie et des débats
qui sont en cours actuellement et tu vas
avoir des recherches qui vont être plus
visible que 2 2 sec de cette là là on se
rapproche un petit peu de robert merton
et de l'effet mathieu dans les faits
mathieu tu retrouveras une vidéo sur sur
la chaîne où j'expliquais terme en ce qu
est l effet mathieu selon robert merton
il nous dit que tu as des chercheurs qui
vont réussir à chercher les bons thèmes
quoi quelque part en ce moment il ya des
thèmes qui vont leur être proposé des
objets qui vont leur être proposées
c'est parce qu'il va les intéresser
parce qu'ils sentent que c'est pas
déterminant quoi socialement et à
l'opposé des chercheurs qui par leur
socialisation par l'heureux leur façon
d'aborder leur leur discipline voilà
sont capables de directement se
positionner sur les thèmes les plus
porteurs socialement voilà ça rejoint ce
à quoi troisièmement la théorie des
intelligences multiples constitue sans
conteste un effort louable démarqua ont
des conceptions classiques
d'intelligence au lieu de se limiter aux
habiletés traditionnellement reconnus
comme des manifestations d'intelligence
elle élargit l'éventail en accordant
aussi un statut égal d'intelligence à
d'autres habiletés présageant
ainsi contrer les échecs scolaires
d'élèves moins performants en matière
logico mathématique et linguistique en
somme garner s'efforce de donner ses
lettres de noblesse à l'intelligence
pour ainsi dire quotidienne mais ce
qu'on efface réellement à une
intelligence qui serait
différente d'une intelligence plus
central plus logico mathématique plus
linguistique qui permettrait d'agir sur
les autres compétences voilà après
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions tu
peux avoir des visées égalitaire et tout
le monde reconnaîtra que l'intention est
louable mais est ce que tu peux le faire
en disant que c'est une théorie
scientifique que l'école traditionnelle
favoris ses efforts en mathématiques et
en français c'est un fait la proposition
de garner de recentrer l'école sur
l'ensemble des intelligences est certes
vertueuse mais elle suppose une
révolution à bien des égards de toute la
société en effet de l'école primaire
jusqu'à l'université la presque totalité
des matières scolaires requiert des
compétences logico mathématique
linguistique et spatiales les élèves qui
présentent des compétences ou des
intérêts relié aux autres formes
d'intelligence peuvent s'inscrire soit
dans des activités parascolaires soit
dans des écoles spécialisées de plus si
la théorie de garner ce rêve elle est
fondée nous devrions procéder à une
révision draconienne des connaissances
acquises sur l'intelligence pour le
moment plusieurs arguments
scientifiquement appuyé circonscrivent
les limites de la théorie de garner
l'une des leçons à tirer de tout ce
débat réside sans doute dans la tendance
à prêter un caractère de vérité à ceux
qui au départ n'est qu'une proposition
et si les intelligences multiples
séduisent autant c'est peut-être
finalement parce qu'elles libèrent les
esprits de l'exigence universel que
représente pour l'intelligence humaine
la maîtrise des savoirs dérivé du
raisonnement logique
néanmoins tout n'est pas négatif dans
cette controverse les vue théorique de
garner sur l'intelligence ont tout de
même permis à plusieurs chercheurs de
conforter les approches classiques de sa
mesure tout en clarifiant le caractère
fondamental de ces aspects logiciels
logico mathématique et linguistique par
ailleurs on ne saurait balayé dur vers
de la main l'effort de garner de
valoriser d'autres domaines plus ou
moins négligée où s'exerce
l'intelligence grâce aux vertus des
divers talents distribués dans les
populations humaines de ces sphères
méconnu où s'entremêlent souvent
l'émotivité et l'intelligence j'haïs des
chefs-d'oeuvre ou tout du moins tout au
moins des savoir-faire susceptibles de
sauvegarder un sentiment de valeur
personnelle chez des individus -
naturellement adapté au système scolaire
à ce titre les chercheurs et les
cliniciens gagnerait à créer des outils
pour déceler puis stimulées des talents
cachés des projets non dits ou tout
simplement des savoir-faire jusque là
ignorées ou dévaluer parle dans leur
milieu et qui sait si l'avenir de la
science cognitive ne résidera pas
justement dans l'accroissement de la
recherche des liens entre l'it
l'intelligence et l'émotivité en tout
cas on ne perdra jamais en limitant le
nombre des mozart assassiné selon
l'expression célèbre danton exupéry et
la théorie de garner si mal fondée soit
elle sur le plan scientifique plaide ou
moins en faveur de la reconnaissance des
talents voilà c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir tu peux considérer que
warner a proposé des choses
intéressantes mais certainement pas
considérer qu'il s'agit de la science
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle voilà tu as
toujours l'intelligence mal logico
mathématique et linguistique qui domine
parce que ce sont à mon sens les vrais
intelligence pour moi l'intelligence
c'est une sorte de logiciel quoi ta
mémoire vive si tu veux si on faire une
métaphore par rapport à l'informatique
cette mémoire vive elle te permet à près
de 2 peut-être faire tourner un logiciel
de jeu de peut-être faire tourner un la
musique de faire de la vidéo de faire de
la 3d mais c'est pas avec notre cerveau
aussi tu veux mais voilà il reste
toujours une hiérarchie maintenant cela
dit est ce que est ce que l'intelligence
c'est tout non évidemment tu assez
différente à lanta 5 à une capacité
aussi parfois émotionnel un maintenant
on parle beaucoup de 2 comment dire de
cui émotionnel ou comme on appelle ça de
quotient émotionnel pardon mais c'est
peut-être cesser les travaux de garner
qui ont permis ces nouveaux champs de
recherche l'émergence de ces nouveaux
champs de recherche quoi ce qui
évidemment tu as des gens qui sont
peut-être comme peut-être une
intelligence logico mathématique
repoussés est je pense au personnage de
sheldon cooper dans the big bang theory
mais qui à côté de ça voilà n'ont aucune
intelligence humaine aucune intelligence
émotionnelle finalement ne ça ne sont
pas capables d'empathie donc évidemment
il faut pas valorisé à outre mesure
l'intelligence logico mathématique et
linguistique et qui a d'autres formes le
truc et que la recherche doit s'y
intéresser mais tu peux pas dire pour
autant que ce sont des intelligences
voilà voyez ici ce qui est intéressant
aussi je terminerais là dessus c'est que
finalement tu peux
comment dire tu peux vite tomber dans du
normatif vous voyez c'est un petit peu
ça ici avec garner et même avec le débat
et les paroles que j'ai ici finalement
il faudrait que machin et pour moi ça
c'est plus la science quand la science
elle doit juste analyser les choses
telles qu'elles sont et s'ils garner et
il a voulu aller plus loin il a voulu
alors je sais pas je connais pas garner
j'aime et j'ai maman jamais regardé fort
et je regarde s'il ya pas des vidéos de
lui sur sur youtube mais voilà il a
voulu aller plus loin quoi 112 qui avait
une visée plus plus sociétale ou plus
sociale s'est passé le mot sociétale est
encore utilisable mais voilà quoi voilà
donc j'espère en tout cas que cette
cette vidéo vous aura permis de
comprendre que la théorie de garner
n'est pas une théorie fondée
scientifiquement
est sujette à beaucoup de critiques et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine je
vous rappelle aussi les rendez-vous
qu'on a pendant la semaine alors c'est
plus des rendez-vous qui sont liées à la
politique on essaie de comprendre les
élections présidentielles françaises le
mercredi on joue à une simulation
politique dans laquelle j'injecte où je
joue le rôle d'un candidat à la
présidentielle la semaine dernière
c'était valérie pécresse ce mercredi ça
sera fabien roussel et jeudi on fait une
émission politique dans laquelle je
réponds à toutes vos questions sur la
présidentielle et on se retrouve
dimanche prochain alors si j'ai pas
d'empêchement c'est plutôt 21h mais si
c'est pas possible ça sera 10h30 bon là
ça sera l'un ou l'autre de toute façon
je vous tiendrai au courant via la
chaîne youtube voilà je vous souhaite un
bon dimanche et je vous dis à très
bientôt
ciao